you
my parents were they were both actors
and when I was born I was a mistake
because they didn't have the money it
really was hard for them when I was
little so they had to work and do
everything and they just took whatever
they could dad was in things like zeg
cars and did a couple of episodes of the
original Doctor Who with William
Hartnell and stuff like that
I thought that I would be perhaps a
writer well I suppose I am a writer but
I didn't think this I was going to be an
actor from quite early on I thought I
would try to be a comedian I wanted to
be somebody like Lily Tomlin who wrote
with Jane Wagner her own material and
did shows that were character based that
was the area I was interested in
I went to university I started English I
met Stephen Fry Hugh Laurie Robbie
Coltrane Ben Elton we all did comedy
together sketch comedy for two years
after I left University at the very
least I did my own sketch show I did
musical theatre I did mime I did all
sorts of stuff I didn't act until I was
27 years old and then even then it was
by accident
Robbie was doing a thing called tutti
frutti John Byrne written it it's a
Scottish character they said we need
someone who can do the accent my mum
Scottish I happen to know Robbie said
you want to come and meet them and it
happened by accident and III didn't know
how to do it I had not been trained and
I was quite nervous and I thought oh
well I suppose it's just like doing a
sketch only for longer which is exactly
what it turned out to be
probably the one I've just done PL
trappers probably the most challenging
because she's so complicated
and you're in two hours you've got to
indicate how complex she is and why and
she's very inconsistent and you know how
people sometimes you just don't know
what you're going to get from them and
this happens with a lot of people who
are addicted to things like drugs or
alcohol or all their own anxieties she
was someone who was so badly damaged
when she was a child she spent a whole
life trying to metabolize that damage I
think a lot of us do
preparation it depends on the part there
was so much information about this woman
so I ingested as much information as I
could over a period of six months listen
to everything watched everything read
everything then the trick is to let go
of all of that information because
you've got to trick your psyche into
pretending that it's someone else and
you can't do that by being conscious of
being that person so it's a very odd
magic trick you know it's more like a
magician's trick than anything else I
think
never let yourself be defined by how you
look never do that because it'll be over
soon and you won't develop so it's just
over so if people go on and on about how
you look you have to challenge it you
can't just take it in you have to
challenge it you have to put up a
barrier against that and you have to
exist as a person and a character and a
brain and that counts for boys as well
but it's particularly bad for girls at
the moment because they seem to be
required to be models as well as act if
someone asks you or says to you that you
have to be thinner then you have to
challenge them by saying why is my
character a thin person is my character
thin because they are suffering from
some sort of eating disorder give me a
reason because if this is a cosmetic
reason then what you want is a model and
not an actress so be firm and know who
you are and what you are because you are
not a model that is other people do that
and they do it very well and it's a
difficult job so don't be put upon and
do not feel as though that's how you
have to be because it's not true and the
more of us who can't er act that the
more it will go as for the rest don't
ever desire to be a star fame is a
by-product of what you do it's just an
accident what you do you must do because
you love it because you enjoy it because
you're good at it because people enjoy
watching you anything else is by-the-by
really and we're all very lucky if we
get work and good work
so make your choices carefully and don't
do things just because they might pay
well do the things that really interest
you do mad wild things go off go go off
do strange things develop yourself
challenge yourself